AWESOME.
THEY ARE ALREADY YELLING AT ME,
I HAVE TO START.
WE BEGIN WITH NEW INFORMATION
FROM THE RIO GRANDE.
IT IS THE MISSING TACTICS
NATIONAL GUARD SHOULDER WHO IS
PRESUMED DREAD, DROWNED,
TRYING TO RESCUE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS FROM THE RIVER.
HE'S BEEN IDENTIFIED,
20-YEAR-OLD VETERAN WHO JOINED
INMATE OF 2019 AFTER SERVING IN
KUWAIT AND IRAQ.
HE WAS DEPLOYED AS PART OF THE
OPERATION LONE STAR.
ON FRIDAY, HE BRAVELY WENT INTO
THE WATER WITH THE HEAVY
CURRENT, THE RIO GRANDE.
HE WITNESSED TWO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS STRUGGLING IN THE
STRONG CURRENT.
THE SEARCH FOR HIS BODY STILL
UNDERWAY.
THE TEXAS RANGERS NOW SAY THOSE
TWO MEN HE WAS TRYING TO SAVE
WERE SMUGGLING DRUGS.
THE SILENCE ON THIS FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN DEAFENING.
BUT GOVERNOR ABBOTT'S STOMACH
SPOKE OUT.
>> IT'S A TRAGEDY.
IT SHOWS HOW DANGEROUS IT IS ON
THE BORDER.
IT SHOWS HEROISM BY THE MEMBERS
OF THE TEXAS NATIONAL GUARD WHO
IS TRYING TO SAVE LIVES.
>> Harris: WE DON'T KNOW WHY
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS NOT SPOKEN
YET.
PERHAPS IT WON'T MAKE A
STATEMENT DEAR MY HOPE IN MY
PRAYERS THAT THAT THEY ARE DOING
SOMETHING FOR BISHOP EVANS
FAMILY THEN WE WILL EVER KNOW.
IT SEEMS GLARING TO MEET.
>> Vivek: FIRST LOOK, LET'S
PAUSE TO THINK ABOUT THIS.
HE IS A NATIONAL HERO.
A 22-YEAR-OLD AMERICAN CITIZEN
LIVING OUT HIS CIVIC DUTY,
SAVING THE LIVES OF TWO DRUG
SMUGGLERS WHO HE THOUGHT WAS
GOING TO DROWN.
IT IS REALLY EASY FOR A LOT OF
AMERICANS TO SIT BACK ON THEIR
COUCHES AND CLAIM THEIR VIEWS ON
IMMIGRATION POLICY OR BORDER
SECURITY POLICY WHEN THEY DO NOT
HAVE SKIN IN THE GAME.
IT IS ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS THAT
REMINDED ME THAT OUR CIVIC
DUTIES OUGHT TO BE SHARED
EVENLY.
IF WE HAD MORE PEOPLE SERVING
THE NATIONAL GUARD, CIVIC
SERVICE WOVEN INTO WHAT YOUNG
PEOPLE GO THROUGH, WE WOULD HAVE
SKIN IN THE GAME AND HAVE VERY
DIFFERENT VIEWS ON HOW WE SHOULD
BE SELLING THE BORDER CRISIS
THAN COMFORTABLY SITTING IN YOUR
HOMES AND LIKE THIS 22-YEAR-OLD
SERVING HIS CIVIC DUTY AND DYING
IN THE PROCESS.
THAT'S WHAT DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS SHOULD BE TALKING
ABOUT.
IF I WAS JOE BIDEN, THAT'S WHAT
I WOULD BE HIGHLIGHTING TODAY.
>> Harris: KENNEDY, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S WORSE.
THE FACT OF WHAT NONE OF THE
VIVEK IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
THAT WE KNOW OF.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PLANETS
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE OR
POTENTIALLY THAT THEY DO NOT
HAVE ONE.
BEFORE A STUNNING LACK OF A
PLANET GOING TO TO MAKE THINGS
EVEN WORSE.
IT PUTS MORE PEOPLE AT RISK.
SO FAR THERE HAVE BEEN 11 PEOPLE
WHO WASHED UP ON THE U.S. SIDE
OF THE YOU STOMACH RIO GRANDE
AND 12 ON MEXICO SIDE.
WHAT BISHOP DID IS THAT HE HAD A
ROOT STOMACH RESPECTIVE HUMAN
LIFE.
HE WASN'T JUDGING HER STORY AND
WHO THEY MIGHT BE.
HE SAW TWO PEOPLE IN TROUBLE AND
PUT HIS LIFE AT RISK.
IT'S A KIND OF SERVICE THAT COME
INTO YOUR POINT, WE HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES WHAT WE DO THIS AND
THEN?
WOULD I BE BRAVE ENOUGH AND
VALUE HUMAN LIFE ENOUGH TO DO
WHAT HE DID?
I FEEL SO BADLY FOR HIS FAMILY,
BUT ALSO, YOU HAVE TO REALIZE
HOW PROUD THEY ARE.
THEY RACE THAT KID RIGHT.
>> Harris: I WANT TO STAY WITH
THE SOLDIER FIRMAMENT.
TONUS CONGER MEN TONY GONZALEZ
TREATED THIS.
A BRAVE NATIONAL GUARDSMEN
REMOVED HIS ARMOR BEFORE JUMPING
INTO THE WATERS TO SAVE HUMAN
LIFE.
PLEASE PRAY FOR THE FAMILIES OF
ALL OF THOSE IMPACTED.
WHEN YOU SEE WHAT HE DID, AND
KENNEDY DESCRIBED IT SO WELL, HE
MADE A CHOICE IN THE MOMENT.
HE TOOK OFF WHAT HE KNEW WOULD
PROTECT HIM IF BULLETS FLEW.
HE COULD GO GET THE PEOPLE THAT
NEEDED HELP.
HE DID NOT KNOW WHO HE WAS
SAVING AND HE DID NOT KNOW THAT
HE RISKED THAT ALL.
>> Emily: HE MADE THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE THAT ALL LIGHTS ARE
CREATED EQUAL.
HE WAS SELFLESS IN THAT MOMENT.
HE HAS A NATIONAL TREASURE, A
HERO.
MY HEART BREAKS FOR HIS FAMILY
OF THE 22-YEAR-OLD SPECIALIST
EVANS WHO, BY THE WAY, BEFORE HE
WAS SERVING IN THE RIVER, HE
ALREADY SERVED IN KUWAIT AND
IRAQ AT THE TENDER ROOT OF 22.
HE WAS PART OF OPERATION
LONE STAR WHICH IS
GOVERNOR ABBOTT'S RESPONSE TO
THE UNCONTROLLABLE SITUATION
DOWN THERE.
THE CRUEL SITUATION THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S POLICIES HAVE
CREATED.
IT IS CRUEL FOR THE MIGRANTS, IT
IS CRUEL FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT,
BORDER PATROL.
>> Harris: IS DANGEROUS.
>> Emily: IT'S CRUEL FOR
LANDOWNERS AND SHERIFF'S GARDEN
IT HAS BEEN CRUEL AND LIVES ARE
BEING LOST.
THERE BEEN TO DROWNINGS A WEEK.
AN EXPECTATION OF 18,000
MIGRANTS A DAY AND IT WOULD
INCREASE.
I HOPE AND I PRAY THAT
SPECIALIST EVANS LIFE, THAT HE
SACRIFICED FOR THIS WONDERFUL
COUNTRY, IT WILL NOT BE IN VAIN.
WE WILL HEAR FROM OUR PRESIDENT
AND HE WILL EXPRESS AN
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OR CONDOLENCE FOR
THIS NATIONAL HERO.
>> Harris: LET'S TALK POLICY.
I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS SO WELL
BECAUSE YOU WERE WITH THE FORMER
ADMINISTRATION THAT SAW THIS
COMING AND TRIED EVERYTHING IT
COULD TO TURN THINGS AROUND AND
PUT TITLE 42 IN PLACE.
NOT GOING TO SUGARCOAT THIS.
WE WEREN'T HAVING PROBLEMS
BEFORE, BUT HE ATTACKED US.
THAT IS THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN WITH THE CURRENT
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Kayleigh: PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID TURN IT AROUND AT THE
BORDER.
THERE WASN'T A SEARCH, BUT HE
FOUND WITH A ZERO-TOLERANCE
POLICY WITH TITLE 42 WITH
ENFORCING THE LAWS OF THE BOOKS
TO BRING THAT UNDER CONTROL.
YOU ARE PREGNANT WITH RECKLESS
ABANDONMENT IS NOT ONLY GOING TO
ROLL BACK TITLE 42 TO APPEASE
THE PROGRESSIVES, BUT
ELIZABETH WARREN ON THE SUNDAY
SHOW.
SHE SAID, "THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PUTTING PLANS IN PLACE" TO DEAL
WITH THE DEMANDING AMNESTY ON
THE BORDER.
DEMANDING AMNESTY.
THIS IS WHAT SENATOR WARREN
TELLS US IS HAPPENING.
>> Harris: WHAT I FIND SO
INTERESTING ABOUT WHAT SHE DOES
AND DOES NOT SAY AS A
PROGRESSIVE IS THAT SHE DOES NOT
GIVE ANY DETAILS ABOUT WHAT THAT
IS GOING TO BE.
HER JOB IS TO SELL IT.
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED THE
PROGRESSIVES.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS
AND WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO FIND
OUT.
NOVEMBER 20 BE HERE IN A
HEARTBEAT.
>> Kayleigh: THIS PRESENTATION
IS THAT HE DOES NOT CARE ABOUT
WINNING THE INDEPENDENCE OR THE
SUBURBAN WOMEN.
HE CARES ABOUT STICKING WITH
AOC.
IT'S WHY HE'S DOING WHAT HE'S
DOING WITH STUDENT LOANS AND
GUIDO FOR THEIR APPEARED TWICE
ROLLBACK TITLE 42 PAIR BUT IF I
COULD SAY ONE THING QUICKLY.
THE STORY BROKE HERE ON FRIDAY
ON "OUTNUMBERED."
A TRAGIC STORY AS WE LEARNED IT.
I SAID THAT I HOPE THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE COMES UP AND SAID
SOMETHING EXPEDITIOUSLY AND
EMPHATICALLY PURE THEY DID NOT,
BUT I WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE
THAT WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE
BORDER STORY
AND HOW THE DHS SECRETARY CAME
OUT WITHIN 48 HOURS AND SAID HE
WAS HORRIFIED AND IT TROUBLED
HIM PROFOUNDLY.
HE SAID PEOPLE ARE
UNDERSTANDABLY UPSET,
HORRIFYING, DON'T HAVE THE FULL
CONTEXT.
THEY WERE SO QUICK TO DEMONIZE
BORDER PATROL.
WHERE ARE THEY IN THE NATIONAL
GUARDSMEN CUSTOMERS THEY
SHOULD'VE BEEN OUT HERE
IMMEDIATELY.
THE POLICY IS WHAT MATTERS.
>> Harris: ALL THAT.
VIVEK, BEFORE WE SCOOT TO
COMMERCIAL, I WANT TO GET YOUR
LAST THOUGHT ON WHERE THE
WHITE HOUSE GOES OUT.
THEY ARE AT THE HEART OF THIS.
>> Vivek: THEY ARE.
AND WE HAVE THE SEPARATE A
PANDEMIC OR POLICY WHERE THEY
ARE USING THE PANDEMIC AS AN
EXCUSE TO EXTEND ALL THINGS.
>> Harris: MASK MANDATES.
>> Vivek: A NUMBER OF OTHER
POLICIES.
VOTING PROCEDURES.
THERE ARE NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
ARE EXTENDED NOW THAT THE
PANDEMIC HAS PASSED.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE HER
ACTUAL REFORMS THAT ALLOW THEM
TO REMOVE ILLEGAL MIGRANTS
QUICKLY.
NOT JUST EXTENDING TITLE 42, BUT
IMPLEMENT THE NEW POLICIES.
THEY'RE GOING TO USE
CONSERVATIVE SUPPORTING THIS AS
A JUSTIFICATION TO ROLL OUT A
BUNCH OF PANDEMIC EMERGENCY
POLICIES AND NEED TO BE
EXTINGUISHED ALONG WITH THE
PANDEMIC.
>> Harris: I'M GOING TO ASK
YOUR TEAM IN THE BOOTH IF WE
COULD ROLL FROM CONGRESS AND
CUELLAR.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY?
>> MY QUESTION HAS, WHO IS
LISTENING TO THE MEN AND WOMEN
IN GREEN AND BLUE AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, WHO IS LISTENING TO
THE BORDER COMMUNITY, SHERIFFS,
LANDOWNERS, THE REST OF THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE ON THE BORDER?
SPILL AND KENNEDY QUESTION MARKS
BEFORE SENATOR WARREN IS NOT
LISTENING TO SENATOR SINEMA
BECAUSE THEY HAVE VASTLY
DIFFERENT VIEWS ABOUT WHAT
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION FORM
WOULD BE.
SOME LIKE KYRSTEN SINEMA WHO IS
VERY MUCH INDEPENDENT, SHE
STANDS WITH HER STATE ON THE
ISSUE.
THEY VIEW IMMIGRATION
DIFFERENTLY THAN THEY DO IN
MASSACHUSETTS.
>> Harris: THEY ARE ON THE
BORDER.
IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
BUT WE ARE ALL BORDER STATES NOW
ACCORDING TO SENATOR BLACKBURN.
SHE BUT THAT S